Das war's für heute.
So, das war's für heute.
So, da bin ich.
Hab ja gesagt, wir gucken uns heute mal ein bisschen Prime Day Angebote an.
Und ich wette mit euch, also ich hab mich gestern gesagt,
ich wette mit euch, es wird wieder nur Mist dabei sein.
Ich lass mich aber gerne eines besseren belehren.
Ich hab nur ein kleines Problem.
Ich bin extrem vollgefressen.
Ich hab noch nicht mal was super Five Head-mäßiges gegessen.
Ich hab den, ich hab nen Plash genommen.
Also mit Backofen, Plash, halbe Packung Pommes frites draufgeschmissen
und ne, ne, ne, fast ne ganze Packung Mozzarella-Sticks.
Hab das für ne halbe Stunde in Backofen geschmissen
und hab das jetzt alles aufgefuttert.
Holkornmilchbrot 16 Monate, das ist ja richtig Hypersubscription.
Direkt zum Streamstart.
Moment, warte mal, die Lautstärke passt nicht.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ah.
Deswegen passt die Lautstärke hier auch nicht.
Jetzt gehts halbwegs.
So.
Okay, ähm.
Samsung Evo 2 und 2TB.
Ja, die ganzen, die ganzen, die ganzen Chia Farmer.
Warum nicht Nintendo Musik?
Und ich mag Nintendo Musik.
Ich mag die meisten aktuell Nintendo Spiele nicht.
Aber Nintendo Musik mag ich.
Es gibt da leider auf der Switch kaum Games.
Ich hab, glaube, ich hab drei Spiele oder so für die Switch.
Also ich hab Breath of the Wild.
Ich hab Mario Odyssey.
Ich hab das Link's Awakening Remake.
Hab ich sonst noch was?
Ich glaube nicht.
Also Krami Witcher und Skyrim kauf ich mir garantiert nicht auf der Switch.
Also im Skyrim ist ja gefühlt auch schon auf jeder Plattform fünfmal erschienen.
Eigentlich fehlt nur noch, eigentlich fehlt doch nur noch GTA V auf der Switch.
Steam um 12.50 Uhr, ja.
Warum nicht?
Kann ja schlecht nur an Mr. Prime, der ja vorbei ist, um zu gucken.
Mal gucken.
Ich glaube Breath of the Wild wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern bis es rauskommt.
Es gibt eigentlich, es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Sachen, die ich mir wünschen würde
für Breath of the Wild.
Der erste Teil war schon vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es vielleicht mal wieder ein paar mehr normale Dungeons
gibt.
Gab es ja im letzten Teil überhaupt nicht.
Diese komischen Roboterviecher, da erzähle ich jetzt mal nicht dabei.
Das war ja wirklich sehr überschaubar.
Und vielleicht ein ordentlicher Soundtrack wäre was.
Ja 2000, das kommt im Leben nicht nix, ja.
Ich meine Nintendo müsste eigentlich nix, weil die haben ja nix.
Ich weiß, ich habe mir mal letztens, ich habe letztens diese Nintendo Direct geguckt.
Da war ja auch wieder, bis auf ein bisschen Breath of the Wild 2 Teaser, da war nix dabei.
Ok, vielleicht für die Metroid Fans, gab es in Metroid was aussieht wie ein Steam Indie
Game.
Nur, dass Samus drin ist.
Aber ansonsten, ja, ich weiß nicht.
Die Nintendo Fans sind halt richtig, also Nintendo Fans sind fast noch schlimmer als damals
Xbox vs.
Playstation Fans.
Ja, ohne Mist.
Ich wollte es nicht unter den Post schreiben, weil ich wusste, dass die Nintendo Fans dann
wieder total eskalieren, wenn ich sowas schraube.
Aber genau das dachte ich mir auch.
Das sah aus wie, keine Ahnung, als hat einer mit ein bisschen Unity Erfahrung versucht,
einen Metroid zu machen.
So.
Bald, ich habe mir nämlich, also einmal muss ich mit dem Noelia noch weitermachen für
den Speed Champ.
Und wir werden tatsächlich das Meme Board mal ein bisschen erweitern, weil es gibt ein
Problem.
Guckt mal.
Das geht schnell anzuzeigen.
Wobei, ich zeige es euch mal.
Das hat nämlich ein paar Bugs, die mir langsam auf den Sack gehen.
Also, so Gifts gehen schnell anzuzeigen.
So Gifts lecken schon ein bisschen.
Normale Bilder gehen immer schnell, überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber etwas größere, detailreiche Gifts sind richtig Paints Champ.
Seht ihr das, wie das laggt?
Also, ich klick, ich klick.
Passt mal auf, ich klick.
Seht ihr, wie das laggt?
Preloaden kannst du den Kram nicht, weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen der Meinung ist, das
Ding der Meinung ist, es muss...
Warte mal, wo ist denn hier der...
Wie heißt denn das?
Web Application.
Das Ding braucht einfach mal 600 MB RAM für so ein Bild.
Ah nee, Moment, das sieht man jetzt gar nicht, ne?
Das ist halt voll der Witz.
Also, das liegt aber an WPF und diesem GIF Renderer, den ich verwende.
Sackt.
Wir machen das jetzt anders.
Aber so detailarme Gifts gehen, aber detaillierte Gifts funktionieren nicht richtig.
Seht ihr ja, braucht ewig.
So, wir werden das ganz einfach machen.
Wir machen billig, transparent das Windows Forms Ding und rendern mit FFmpeg selbst
und dann sollte das eigentlich halbwegs schnell gehen.
Nein, Elektron ist für sowas nicht sonderlich sinnvoll.
Achso, du meinst, bei der RAM-Auslastung kann ich gleich Elektron nehmen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber für Elektron ist sowas wirklich nicht gut.
Versuchen wir mit Elektron Transparenz hinzubekommen, dass man durchklicken kann.
Ich kann ja hier durchklicken.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, so native Sachen unter Elektron einzustellen.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Ja, das Problem an Breath of the Wild, was ich hatte, das Klaviergedudel war ja okay.
Aber das ganze Game, vor allem auch bei irgendwelchen epischeren Fights,
der einzige gute Soundtrack von Breath of the Wild war im Abspann.
Und der Trailer. Der Trailer hat einen richtig guten Soundtrack.
Das war es dann aber auch.
Was ist das hier für Cute Emotes?
Bei B.
Ich habe nie gehört.
Ein Nintendo Shit Repo.
Ich glaube, Nintendo ist der letzte Laden, der irgendwie agil GitHub verwendet.
Das kann ich mir bei Nintendo einfach nicht vorstellen.
Könnt ihr euch ernsthaft Nintendo agil auf GitHub vorstellen?
Ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist ohne Scheiß die letzte Firma,
den letzten Spieleentwickler, den ich mir vorstellen kann,
der da irgendwie sowas machen würde.
Nintendo ist, glaube ich, immer noch eine, die abends die Festplatten
aus den Rechner, den Entwickler ausbauen und den Safe im Keller legen,
so nach dem Motto.
Bist du nicht am Arbeiten?
Wenn ich am Arbeiten wäre, könnte ich ja nicht streamen.
Nintendo-Fans sind immer gehypt.
Ja, ich habe es in der letzten Nintendo Direct gesehen.
Das war wirklich grausam.
Was ist GitHub?
Das ist sowas wie Facebook nur für Programmierer.
Captain Peng, danke schön für den Zapp.
Tri-Fi-Empfang.
Ja, dann.
Hoffentlich klappt es.
Nintendo-Fans sind immer richtig gehypt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Auf alles.
Das siehst du immer an Nintendo-Posts.
Die Nintendo-Posts auf Twitter sind so richtig schlecht aus.
Und keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich werden Nintendo-Twitter-Posts
vom Japanischen ins Englische und vom Englischen ins Deutsche übersetzt.
So lesen die sich immer.
Also die meisten Sachen lesen sich richtig holprig.
Ja, das ist so.
Ist auch egal.
Und wenn du die Antworten darauf siehst,
Nintendo kündigt irgendeinen Müll an und die Leute auf Twitter
alle gleich wieder.
Oh ja, da warte ich schon mein ganzes Leben darauf.
Danke Nintendo, dass ihr das released.
Also, egal.
Letztendlich Fanboys in jeder Art und Weise sind immer
richtiger Pains-Champ.
Alter, was ist das für ein Gedudel?
24 hours relaxing Nintendo-Music, perfekt.
Nee, das ist zu relaxing.
Alter, ich brauch mal irgendwas, was ein bisschen...
Jawoll.
Das ist, das ist, das ist Pippen-Jam.
Nee, äh, Cat-Jam, Pippen-Please, wie auch immer.
So ist das gut.
24 Stunden Streamer, Video geht nur zwölf.
Das ist immer...
Wir sind schon gescampt, was die Videozeit angeht.
Passt, wir sind nur aus elf.
Also, wir gucken jetzt mal bei Amazon rein.
Oder bei Amazon, wie die coolen Leute das sagen.
Oh, warum ist das eine Giraffe?
Toss, Toss.
Man sieht das Ding von der Giraffe, Alter.
Schnell, schnell ausblenden.
Wann denkst du, sind Grafikkarten wieder verfügbar?
Ja, jetzt so langsam, jetzt so langsam.
Man sieht das ja schon hier, guck mal.
Das ist in den letzten Tagen...
Es ist wieder ein bisschen, es ist wieder ein bisschen runtergegangen.
Also, Grafikkarten sind jetzt, sind jetzt verfügbar.
Es ist hier, es ist alles, es ist kontinuierlich, kontinuierlich ein bisschen gefallen.
Aber natürlich ist es immer noch viel zu teuer, ne?
Aber du kriegst jetzt aktuell wieder Grafikkarten.
Ich denke mal, so zum normalen Preis, wahrscheinlich...
Wann kommt denn der Nachfolger von der...
Was ist denn eigentlich der Nachfolger von 130.90?
Wie werden die denn dann heißen?
4.090?
NVIDIA 4000, wann kommt das raus?
NVIDIA bestätigt Nachfolger von RTX, wer hätte das gedacht?
Ne, Leute, ich hab jetzt ganz ehrlich gedacht, NVIDIA sagt...
Nein, wir hören auf, Grafikkarten zu produzieren nach der aktuellen Serie.
Logisch, ne?
Flow the Game, dankeschön für den Sub.
Der Krümel hat auch Subscribed, dankeschön, 5 Monate Hyper-Subscription.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass die 3900 ungefähr zum Release der nächsten Generation wieder zu UVP verfügbar ist.
Ich kauf mir die nächste Generation.
Also nächste Generation, wenn das besser wird, kauf ich mir auf jeden Fall wieder eine.
Bis dahin macht es meine 1080 Ti noch.
Die 1080 Ti war einfach richtig geiles Poggers-Teil, als es rausgekommen ist.
Man darf nicht vergessen, ich hab das Ding jetzt dreieinhalb Jahre oder so.
Und geht immer noch, was ist das? 1080 Ti Release, wann war denn das?
Ah, ja.
Ne.
Ich hab, ich hab die 4, ich hab die fast schon, an die 4 Jahre die Grafikkarte.
Lull.
4 Jahre und das Ding ist immer noch top.
Kannst dich echt nicht beschweren.
Die war einfach praktisch zu schnell für Nvidia, als sie rausgekommen ist.
Aber ich kauf mir, ich kauf mir eine neue, also die 4000er Series kauf ich mir dann.
Kannst du einen smarten Rauch- und CO2-Melder empfehlen?
Ne, kann ich nicht, da bin ich selbst danach am suchen.
Die, die ich bisher gesehen hab, sind Müll.
Sodass ich, ich hab keine, ich hab keine.
Also was ich gerne hätte, wäre ja einen Rauchmelder, der den Batteriestatus überträgt, irgendwo hin.
Anderweitig smart müssten die gar nicht sein.
Also was relativ beliebt ist, ist von, wie heißt die, Nest?
Das ist Google, aber will ich halt nicht.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
So, so einfach ist das nicht.
Die, die Dinger von Nest sind relativ beliebt, aber das ist halt Nest.
Auf Nest hab ich keinen Bock.
Und die sollen auch ab und zu mal ein paar Fehlerlarme produzieren.
Rauchmelder in Home Assisted kannst du machen, ja.
Du brauchst halt, du brauchst halt in irgendeiner Art und Weise einen Rauchmelder, der Zeug überträgt.
Also die Nest-Dinger kannst du in Home Assisted verwenden.
Das ist kein Ding, aber Nest-Rauchmelder.
Aber ich bin kein großer Nest-Fan.
Zumal die auch ihre öffentliche APF, die alle benutzen können, abgeschaltet haben.
Und ich hab gelesen, dass das Zeug ab und zu mal Fehlerlarme produziert.
Oh.
Na gut.
Gehen wir mal, gehen wir mal auf Amazon, was Amazon so zu bieten hat.
Jetzt ist Prime Day, ich find's immer noch sehr irritierend, dass Prime Day zwei Tage lang ist.
Ja, 129 Euro für einen Rauchmelder.
Also, was ich mir überlegt hab ist, ich lass das einfach rauchmeldertechnisch so wie es ist.
Ich hab in jedem Zimmer, außer im Schlafzimmer, den hab ich gerade ab, weil die Batterie leer ist.
Brauche ich einen neuen, ich hab hier so ein 10-Jahres-Ding.
Und da kannst du die Batterie ja nicht wechseln.
Und der hat gepiept die ganze Zeit.
Und da muss man neuer hin.
Ich lass jetzt einfach die anderen Rauchmelder hier dran.
Solang es nicht gescheiten, smarten Rauchmelder gibt, der den Alarmstatus,
beziehungsweise vor allem den Batteriestatus irgendwie überträgt.
Tja.
Und wenn's brennt...
Da sind ja meistens integriert CO2 und Rauchmelder.
Doch, das ist gar nicht so unsinnig.
Das ist gar nicht so unsinnig, weil wenn du schläfst und es brennt irgendwo,
dann bekommst du das nicht mit.
Die meisten Leute kratzen ab, weil sie überrascht werden,
weil sie am Pennen sind und dann Rauchvergiftung.
Easy F in den Chat.
Also Rauchmelder sind nicht verkehrt, kosten auch nicht viel.
So, also zeig mal her.
Was hat an Amazon Schönes?
Ich hab, wie gesagt, meine persönliche Vermutung ist,
es ist wieder nur Mist dabei.
Also extrem viel useless Shit, den man nicht braucht.
Was es gibt heute unter anderem die Rubindüse.
Was für ein Ding?
Die Rubindüse.
Rubinose für 3D-Drucker.
Und was kann die besser?
Außer, dass sie einen Rubin vorne drin hat.
Also ist das irgendein Vorteil, dass das Filament
sich durch einen Rubin durchquetschen muss,
anstatt es einfach durch Metall?
Es gibt von Homatic IP-Kuhle.
Ja, nicht unbedingt, aber Homatic kannst du auch in Home Assistant
ganz gut einbinden mittlerweile.
Rubinose, ja.
Bessere Hitzekontrolle, okay.
Aber für den Preis kann ich mir wahrscheinlich 20 normale
Nozzles kaufen.
Wenn man das braucht, ist es wahrscheinlich echt ganz cool.
Wobei, wo ist das Angebot für 40 Euro?
Ach, das wird hier gar nicht angezeigt,
weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Oh, das ist ja wieder Paints-Champiger, Paints-Champ.
Okay, Prime-Angebote.
Also, beginnen Sie jetzt.
Nee, nee, nee, passt schon, alles gut.
Ich kann das zum Glück so angucken.
Der Preis pro 100 Gramm, ja, er gibt bei so was wenig Sinn,
aber wahrscheinlich sind Sie verpflichtet dazu.
Ich könnte mal die Klimaanlage einschalten,
obwohl es schon deutlich kühler ist als gestern,
aber es ist gerade wieder 27 Grad hier drin.
Hier läuft halt zwei Rechner, zwei Monitore und sonst was.
Wird es halt relativ schnell warm, wenn die Tür zu ist.
So, also, fangen wir mal an.
Eine Sache, was immer sinnvoll ist bei Amazon,
sind die Amazon-eigenen Geräte, wenn man sie braucht.
Ich brauch sie aber halt nicht mehr,
weil ich schon alles hab, was ich brauche.
Echo kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ich hab keinerlei Alexa- oder Google-Dings.
Wie heißen die Google Assistant?
Wie heißen die Lautsprecher von Google denn?
Die heißen auch nicht gut Google Assistant Speaker oder so.
Wie heißt der Gramm? Google Home? Nee, das ist Apple.
Wie heißt es?
Sind die auch von Nest, die Google Assistant Speaker?
Was auch immer.
Ich hab weder Alexa noch Google Assistant
noch sonst irgendwelche Voices,
deswegen kann ich dazu gar nichts sagen.
Das Einzige, was immer relativ interessant ist,
sind, also für mich, aber ich brauch's grad aktuell nicht,
sind die Tablets.
Firestick kann man sich geben, wenn man will.
Wenn man mit Laggy-Interface klarkommt,
ist da Firestick in Ordnung.
Es geht nichts von der Bedienung
und wie weich die Bedienung und wie flüssig die Bedienung.
Es geht nichts über einen Shield-TV.
Das ist das Beste, was man sich kaufen kann,
ist aber natürlich auch eine ganze Ecke teurer.
Einen Shield-TV kannst du fast nur null hinten dranhängen.
Guck mal, ob die irgendwas im Angebot haben.
Das neue Shield-TV ist so hässlich.
Das ist so hässlich.
Ich weiß nicht, was...
Hier, das ist das Pro.
Ich weiß nicht, was die sich dabei gedacht haben.
Das ist das Normale.
So sahen die alten eigentlich immer aus.
Jetzt hast du was zum Hinstellen.
Früher hast du es hingelegt.
Da kannst du fast nur eine Null dranhängen.
Ich hab alles durchprobiert.
Ich hatte einen Firestick, hab ich ausprobiert.
Ich habe einen Raspberry Pi ausprobiert.
Und ich hab einen Shield-TV.
Aber mein Shield-TV ist auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Ich hab alles durchprobiert.
Ganz ehrlich, das Shield-TV ist mit Abstand,
mit riesem Abstand das Beste.
Das ist einfach...
Du drückst drauf und es macht instant was.
Der Raspberry Pi ist, was bei Kodi als Oberfläche
oder was auch immer angeht, laggy as fuck.
Das zuzukommt, dass es keine richtigen Apps drauf gibt
und du dementsprechend nichts mit abspielen kannst.
Und der Fire-TV-Stick ist ein ganz normales Android-TV,
allerdings veramazonifiziert und auch ein bisschen laggy.
Ganz ehrlich, Shield-TV ist echt das Beste, was es gibt.
Apple-TV ist auch superflott für Apple-User.
Ja, da kann ich nichts zu sagen, das hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
Und das Shield-TV ist halt echt super.
Du kriegst Updates.
Ich hab das jetzt schon seit, keine Ahnung, drei oder vier Jahren.
Es gibt immer noch Updates.
Du hast alle möglichen Apps, die du brauchst.
Von Netflix bis Mediathek bis Amazon bis alles eigentlich.
Zumal du auch Android-Side-Loaden kannst.
Das ist eigentlich fast das Beste.
Und einfach, das ist top.
Kann ich mich echt nicht beschweren.
Ich hab noch, ich hab kein Shield.
Also mein Shield-TV ist noch älter.
Das hat nicht das gute Upscaling.
Das hat noch ziemlich verkacktes Upscaling.
Was aber kein Problem ist, weil ich upscale einfach nicht.
Also ich lass meinen Fernseher upscalen.
Ich mach 1080p in Fernseherein.
Und der Fernseher macht es dann upscale auf 4K.
Weil es halt ein 4K-Panel.
Da muss halt immer hoch skaliert werden.
Der macht das okay.
Doch, du kannst den Browser ausführen auf Shield-TV.
Mit verschiedenen Möglichkeiten.
Du kannst Firefox-Side-Loaden.
Der lässt sich mittlerweile mit Fernbedienung ganz gut bedienen.
Oder mein persönlicher Tipp wäre.
Man nimmt den Silk-Browser vom Fire-TV-Stick.
Und macht den sich auf Shield-TV.
Das ist, finde ich, der beste Browser zum Bedienen mit der Fernbedienung.
Man kann doch auch alles vom Handy casten.
Das hab ich so noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das funktioniert.
4K Amazon vom Handy zu casten.
Keine Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ja, geht bestimmt auch.
Da brauchst du halt einen Fernseher, der Chromecast oder so was kann.
Ja, kannst du auch machen.
Und wie willst du auf deinem Handy...
Willst du da aufgenommenen Fernseher, Fernsehsender, casten?
Geht das auch irgendwie?
Keine Ahnung.
Das Shield-TV hat Chromecast.
Ja, aber es ging ja gerade darum, ob man das nicht auch direkt vom Handy alles machen kann.
Ja, also kann man bestimmt auch machen.
Aber ich geh mal davon aus, unterm Strich ist es trotzdem komfortabler.
Aber es geht ja gerade darum, ob man das nicht auch direkt vom Handy alles machen kann.
Ja, also kann man bestimmt auch machen.
Aber ich geh mal davon aus, unterm Strich ist es trotzdem komfortabler, das im Shield-TV zu machen.
Was ist da mit casten los?
Ja, das müsste ich auch gern.
Ich hab dem MasterCrabber vor, keine Ahnung, einem Monat mal ne Message geschrieben.
Ich hab nie wieder was von gehört.
Also der SMS.
So, also erst mal zurück zu den Amazon-Geräten.
Also, Fire-TV kann man sich geben, wenn man sowas unbedingt haben will.
Echo kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Das Einzige, was für mich immer ganz interessant ist, sind die Tablets.
Aber die brauch ich jetzt nicht, weil ich hab schon genug.
Irgendwann ist auch mal Kaboom.
Ich hab grad gelesen im Chat, wie geht's denn Kaboom?
Dem geht so weit Schweiß ganz gut.
Ich hab aber mittlerweile genug Fire Tablets.
Und solange meine zwei Dashboards oben und unten im Flur noch funktionieren,
brauch ich keine neuen Fire Tablets.
Ich benutze diese Fire Tablets ja nicht, um damit wirklich täglich was Großartiges zu machen,
sondern eher so als Dashboards, weil ansonsten sind die mir auch ein bisschen zu mickrig.
Also nicht von der Größe her, sondern von dem, was drin ist.
Die Sache mit oder ohne Werbung ist vollkommen egal,
weil das Erste, was man machen sollte, ist eh das Ganze zu deep-loaden.
Also das ist egal, ihr könnt es ruhig mitwerben und kaufen.
Und am besten ist, wenn man das nicht eilig hat und man sich so ein Fire Tablet einfach mal gönnt
und man wartet 1-2 Jahre oder ein halbes Jahr bis zu einem Jahr oder was auch immer,
bis es Custom-Firmware gibt, die man flashen kann.
Da muss man immer schauen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die aktuellen HD-10s flashbar sind.
Man kann die aber auch so ganz gut deep-loaden.
Also entweder macht man komplett Custom-Firmware drauf
oder man nimmt die Amazon Toolbox
oder man nimmt die Fire Toolbox.
Ich bin jetzt aber nicht sicher, ob das hier der richtige Thread ist.
Damit kann man auch relativ einfach deep-loaden, einfach USB anschließen und gut ist.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das wirklich sinnvolle Sachen entfernt im Vergleich zu Windows.
Das kann man machen.
Aber am besten ist natürlich, man kann sie komplett flashen.
Anschließen, USB, deep-loaden, zwei Sachen anklicken und gut ist.
Also das lohnt sich immer zum Prime-Day, wirklich, wenn man sowas braucht.
Ich kann die Dinge halt nicht wirklich empfehlen zum täglich benutzen.
Ich hab die als Dashboard an der Wand hängen, da klickt man zu mal drauf
oder lässt sich die Kamera vom Hoftor anzeigen oder sowas.
Aber für mehr, für mehr wird sie nicht verwenden.
Zum täglichen Benutzen habe ich mir mittlerweile sogar selbst noch ein zweites iPad bestellt,
was ich jetzt benutze als Tablet für, was weiß ich, wenn ich im Bett lege
oder wenn ich auf dem Klo bin oder sonst was.
Da komme ich viel, viel besser mit klar als mit Android Tablets.
Wie gesagt, ich habe alles zu Genüge ausprobiert.
Kann jeder machen, was er will, aber Android Tablets finde ich zum größten Teil ziemlich nervig.
Smartphone lasse ich mir gefallen, okay.
80 Euro, die Herstellung kostet bestimmt mehr Geld, das holen sie durch Werbung wieder rein.
Ja, aber nicht bei Leuten, die das ganze deep-loaden, da ist nämlich die Werbung weg.
Hast du Tap to Wake hinbekommen, habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Nein, ich lade keine Videos bei X-Share hoch.
Wie kommst du denn auf sowas?
Nein, ich habe die Message schon richtig gelesen.
Ich benutze das zum Lokalscreenshot machen und lade nichts hoch von.
Hast du ein Tutorial zum deep-loaden?
Wie gesagt, nehme diese Amazon Fire Toolbox, schließ das Ding bei USB an und führ es aus.
Dann kannst du es einfach mit der Tablet ausprobieren.
Nehmen diese Amazon Fire Toolbox, schließ das Ding bei USB an und führ es aus.
Das war's.
Da braucht man kein Tutorial für.
Und ansonsten, such mal, auf YouTube gibt es auch Tausende Tutorials für.
Das ist für mich persönlich das einzig interessante Angebot, was es immer gibt.
Bei diesen Fire Geräten, der Rest ist Resilient Sleeper.
Fire Smart TV wird ja immer schlimmer, der Kram auch noch integriert im Fernsehen.
Irgendwelche Lämpchen.
Was ist denn das?
Der Fire Cube.
Ist das jetzt eine Art Shield TV mit Alexa von Amazon oder?
Was zum Geil ist denn der?
Der Fire TV Cube.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Amazon, Amazon Kram.
Es ist quasi ein Fire Stick mit Alexa oder sowas.
Jetzt kommt das ganze Ringzeug, das kommt mir auch nie im Leben ins Haus.
Also es ist ja schön und gut, wenn es eine Türklingel gibt mit einer Kamera.
Aber dass die Türklingel von mir ein Monatsabo haben will, dass ich das alles richtig verwenden kann, da hört es bei mir auf.
Wenn es optional wäre und ich das dann quasi auch, sagen wir mal, auf einem eigenen NAS speichern könnte, wäre ja okay.
Aber die Funktion gibt es soweit, ich weiß nicht.
Fire HD 8 ist auch eine super Geschichte.
50 Euro kannst du eigentlich überhaupt nichts falsch machen.
Die bloatet, das ist ein super Tablet.
Wohlgemerkt nicht zum täglichen Benutzen.
Also für irgendwas, wo das rumliegt und man ab und zu mal drauf drückt, das ist okay.
Aber fürs tägliche Benutzen sind die viel zu schwachbrüstig.
Also als Main Tablet sind die zu schwach.
Echo Auto, die haben so viele Dinge, wo ich nicht mal weiß, was es ist.
Amazon Wifi, Echo Flex.
Das Zeug hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Okay, es ist im Prinzip nichts interessantes drin, außer vielleicht der Fire TV Stick, falls das irgendjemand haben will.
Oder eben die Tablets.
Aber wie gesagt, alles nur die bloatet, ansonsten kriegt ihr Anfälle wegen der Werbung.
Ja, Apple Geräte sollen tatsächlich auch im Angebot sein, habe ich gelesen, was mich jetzt persönlich ja wundert.
Denn das macht die normalerweise nicht.
Aber im September kommen ja wahrscheinlich neue iPhones, die wollen den Kram jetzt rausbekommen.
Doch, doch, waren glaube ich auch.
Lohnt es sich, über Virtual Box im Netz zu surfen, um die ganze Geschichte mit Cookies und Datenspeicherung zu vermeiden?
Ja, das lohnt sich.
Die Sache ist nur die, wenn du einfach alles in der VM machst, dann hast du ja wieder das gleiche Problem.
Verstehst du, wie ich das meine?
Wenn du eine VM hast und machst einfach alles über die VM, dann hast du ja nichts an Privacy gespart,
weil du machst im Prinzip alles, was du vorher über deinen normalen Browser gemacht hast, jetzt in der VM.
Der Browser in der VM ist ja nicht prinzipiell sicherer, nur weil er in einer VM ist, was Cookie und Tracking angeht.
Was du aber machen kannst, ist, wenn du ab und zu auf ein paar Seiten gehst, wo du dir nicht so ganz sicher bist,
was da so abgeht und wo du nicht ganz sicher bist, ob die sich darauf anlegen, dir irgendwelche Viren unterzuschieben oder sonst wie,
dann ist das tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll, wenn du eine Linux VM machst und darüber surfst.
Also, ich mache alle fragwürdigen Seiten immer in meiner Linux VM auf.
Ja.
So, wir surfen ja auch gerade über Linux VM.
Die Luft ist so trocken mit der Klimaanlage, aber ansonsten ist es so warm. Machen wir es mal wieder aus.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich jetzt noch ein iPhone 12 lohnt.
Ich fand es schon von Anfang an, dass sich ein iPhone 12 nicht gelohnt hat, weil das iPhone 12 hatte ziemlich schlechte Akkulaufzeiten.
Im Vergleich zu dem davor. Und ich hoffe, sollten die dann iPhone 13 oder so rausbringen, dass es dann wieder so gut läuft wie das 11er von den Akkulaufzeiten,
aber eben die Power von dem 12er hat.
Leute, ich muss noch kurz die Nase putzen.
So, Spiel besser. Also, deswegen, ich finde es lohnt sich noch. Also aktuell würde ich kein iPhone 12 mal kaufen.
Wie machst du das mit dem Desktopwechsel?
Ich drücke Ctrl-Windows-Taste, Pfeil links, Pfeil rechts. Und wenn du in der VM bist, dann hast du das Problem, das du gerade beschreibst, dass du das nicht machen kannst.
Du kannst aber vorher Ctrl-Alt drücken, dann jumpt er aus der VM raus und dann drückst du links-rechts.
Also, wenn ich hier in der VM trete, drücke ich Ctrl-Alt, Ctrl-Windows und dann links-rechts. Das macht im Prinzip gar keinen großen Unterschied.
Das sind ja fast die gleichen Knöpfe.
Drückst Ctrl-Alt, dann geht er aus der VM raus und dann Ctrl-Windows zum Switchen.
Oder du kannst es auch umlegen auf irgendein anderes Shortcut, was dir lieber ist.
AddGuard Home bringt dir auch nur beschränkt was.
Ach so, Moment, ist die Antwort da drauf.
Kann man machen, ist okay. Leider auf den Seiten, wo es drauf ankommt, nämlich Twitch und YouTube und sowas, auf einem Smartphone zu blockieren.
Da versagen beide, weil eben YouTube und Twitch mittlerweile, oder gerade Twitch ist da besonders clever,
die liefern mittlerweile Content und Werbung von den gleichen Servern aus,
sodass so Sachen wie Piehole und AddGuard Home das mit DNS-Blocken rein technisch gesehen gar nicht mehr machen können.
Also, die können das gar nicht, gar nicht mehr blockieren.
Und deswegen hast du da nicht viel Spaß mit.
Bestes Prime-Day-Angebot, aber bis jetzt haben wir nichts Großartiges gefunden.
Das können wir uns gleich mal angucken, das ist eine gute Idee.
Wollen wir jetzt das Apple-Zeug angucken? Gucken wir mal.
Wo findet man hier den Raspberry Pi überhaupt drin?
In welcher Kategorie ist er denn hier zu finden?
Computer und Zubehör?
Oder ich kann hier oben einfach Prime-Day-Sachen, Prime-Day-Pi vor.
Das erscheint mir jetzt relativ teuer.
Zumal da wieder 30 Milliarden Sachen dabei sind, die man nicht braucht.
Lass mal kurz gucken. Ich sag dir, ob sich das lohnt.
Ach so, das ist ein Dreier. Hä? Was?
Das ist eindeutig ein Vierer. Ach, ein Upgrade für den Dreier.
Okay, naja.
So, also. 109 für die 4-Gigabyte-Version.
Gucken wir mal.
Hier ist das Berry-Base, dieser deutsche Shop.
Guck mal, was der da grad kostet.
Wir gucken mal, was der normalerweise gerade kostet.
Der Neue. Was ist denn an dem jetzt neu?
Ach so, das ist der Raspberry Pi 4-Stack.
Es gibt wieder einen neuen, einen neuen, neuen Raspberry Pi 4.
Okay, also der 4-G.
57 Euro. Okay, das heißt,
man bekommt quasi hier einen Raspberry Pi 4 mit 4-G.
Und der Rest ist zusammen doch im Leben keine 50 Euro extra wert.
Wie viel Gigabyte würdest du überhaupt empfehlen?
4 sind okay. 4 sind gut. 8 sind zu viel.
8 brauchst du nicht. 2 gehen auch.
2 oder 4. Ich würde 4 nehmen.
Ich hab einen mit 8-G hier, aber das ist komplett useless.
Also ich hab den einfach nur gekauft, weil es geht.
Nicht, weil es irgendwie sinnvoll wäre.
Also es gibt kaum sinnvolle Anwendungen für 8-G auf den Raspberry Pi.
Weil man kann sich da sicherlich welche zusammendichten.
Aber es gibt nicht viele.
Windtube, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Also, das lohnt sich, glaube ich, nicht.
Du kriegst einen Raspberry Pi. Du kriegst ein ziemlich, ziemliches billiges Gehäuse,
so wie es aussieht.
Du kriegst ein paar Passivkühler, die man nicht wirklich braucht,
weil man hier schon einen aktiven Kühler hat.
Dann ist hier nochmal das Gehäuse. Das hatten wir schon.
Dann kriegst du einen USB-Stick, der richtig schlecht aussieht.
USB-Kabel.
Einen billigsten Schraubendreher auf der Welt.
Und einen Netzteil. Nee, das lohnt sich nicht.
Also das Angebot.
Das lohnt sich höchstens, weil man noch wirklich gar nichts hat
und wirklich komplett alles braucht.
Die SD-Karten sind übrigens auch nicht die guten.
Die sehen auf den ersten Blick aus wie Samsung-SSDs.
Nur, dass da oben nicht Samsung drauf steht.
Aber von der Optik her sehen die genau aus wie Samsung-SSDs.
Wenn ihr Raspberry-Pi-SSDs, äh, äh, äh, Mikro-SD, nicht SSDs.
Was laber ich denn für Zeug?
Wenn ihr Mikro-SD-Karten haben wollt, dann sind die Samsung Endurance echt gut.
Aber...
Also die sind super. Die habe ich mittlerweile auch in einigen drinne.
Die halten. Die halten auch ordentlich.
Aber das Beste, was man mittlerweile machen kann,
ist eigentlich eine günstige SSD an Raspberry Pi dran.
SSD, SSD an Raspberry Pi dran ist eigentlich das Beste.
Die Dinger halten. Da muss man sich keine Gedanken machen, dass das irgendwie kaputt geht.
Ach nee, Sandisk ist es. Sandisk ist es.
Okay, das lohnt sich hier noch weniger. Ist noch teurer.
Also das Einzige, was man ehrlich gesagt zum Starten braucht, ist
Raspberry Pi 4 und ein Netzteil.
4 und ein Netzteil.
Raspberry Pi 4 und ein Netzteil. Fertig.
Netzteil würde ich empfehlen.
Man kann das Ding natürlich auch an jedem x-beliebigen USB-Anschluss hängen. Das geht.
Aber Netzteil hat schon den Vorteil,
dass das ein 5,1 Volt, 3 Ampere Netzteil glaube ich ist.
Und gerade der Raspberry Pi 4, wenn der ordentlich ausgelastet wird,
der zieht auch mal ganz gerne so 10 Watt oder so.
10, 12 Watt.
Aber da musst du schon richtig auslasten, das Zeug.
Normalerweise hat der so, was weiß ich,
4 oder 4,5.
Welche SSD benutzt du?
Ich habe, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich
insgesamt drei verschiedene oder vier verschiedene SSDs.
Ich habe Samsung, Samsung Evo SATA.
Ich habe Samsung, äh,
ne, ich, also, ich habe Samsung, ich habe Samsung
KUVO SATA.
Ich habe Samsung Evo M2.
Ich habe ein paar billige Sandis zum Zeug draufdampen.
Und, äh, die, wie heißen die anderen?
Diese M, M, M, Mx 400.
Von welchem Hersteller sind denn die?
War das Corsair?
Ne, von welchem Hersteller sind die?
Äh, weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Crucial, Crucial, genau.
Die sind auch ganz gut.
Die habe ich auch noch am Start.
Aber der Rechner hier, auf dem wir jetzt hier gerade sind,
der hat, ähm,
man sieht, man sieht jetzt nicht alles, ja.
Weil das ein bisschen anders positioniert ist.
Das ist eine M2.
512G, äh, 500G M2.
Das ist eine, ein Terabyte M2.
Die ist aber partitioniert.
Und nur die hier ist unverschlüsselt.
Die anderen 500G sind verschlüsselt.
Und dann hängt noch eine Acht oder Sechs.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, acht, ich glaube, acht Terabyte oder sogar eine Zeh-,
ich weiß es nicht.
Ein paar Terabyte große normale Magnetfestplatte drin.
Also die beiden Angebote, Angebote
lohnen sich aus meiner Sicht nicht.
Wofür braucht man so einen Raspberry Pi?
Wenn man da gar keinen, also wenn man
noch keinen Anwendungszweck für hat, braucht man ihn wahrscheinlich
gar nicht.
Also, ähm, wenn man nicht schon was im
Kopf hat, oder irgendwie
ein bisschen mit Hilfsraum basteln will, braucht man wahrscheinlich
erstmal gar keinen. Aber es gibt schon ein paar ganz
gute Anwendungszwecke. Also was ich zum Beispiel habe
ist, ich habe ein Dashboard, aber das ist jetzt
mit dem Raspberry Pi Zero in dem Fall.
Ich habe ein Dashboard für meine Heizung,
was übrigens gerade kaputt ist, weil das
Kabel-Rip ist, aber aus und
vor.
Der Raspberry Pi Zero im Keller
liest Werte aus der Heizung aus.
Dann habe ich einen Server für meinen 3D-Trucker,
wo ich dann Models
hochladen kann, starten, stoppen, Temperatur
kontrollieren kann.
Was habe ich noch? Dann habe ich einen
Raspberry Pi unten für das WLAN
und für die Videoüberwachungssoftware.
Ich glaube, das war's.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz falsch liege, habe ich
ne, vier, vier. Ich habe vier Raspberry Pies.
Ich habe den, ich habe
die Kamera für einen Hof.
Ich habe den,
also ich habe einen Raspberry Pi Zero
für die Kamera für einen Hof. Ich habe
einen Zero für die Heizung
im Keller zum Auslesen.
Ich habe einen OctoPie für einen 3D-Trucker.
Und ich habe
einen UniFi bzw.
Kamera
bzw. Kamera
wie heißt das?
Surveillance Software
Raspberry Pi
unten im Wohnzimmer
noch stehen. Ich glaube, das war's.
Ja, und allen anderen
Kram, den ich laufen habe, von
Home Assistant bis zu
einem lokalen Wiki
und Gedöns.
Das habe ich nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen.
Kann man da aber drauf laufen lassen. Das habe ich auf einer 2 HE.
Kann ich dir zeigen.
Das habe ich auf einer 2 HE
Intel x86
Low-Power-Kiste laufen.
Guck mal, hier habe ich schon
irgendwie irgendwo
Serverraum 2021.
Da sieht man es doch.
Da ist der 3D-Trucker.
Da unten, wirklich
erkennen tut man da
nix. Ziemlich, ziemlich schlechter
Winkel, den ich hier habe.
Zeige ich das irgendwann nochmal?
Ja, hier, guck.
Das ist die 2 HE-Kiste,
wo das meiste eigentlich drauf läuft.
Das meiste läuft bei mir gar nicht
auf dem Raspberry Pi.
xMore, danke schon für den Sub.
Das meiste läuft hier drauf.
Ich habe
die alte 4 HE-Kiste
mit dem 8-Kern Xeon
ersetzt durch so eine Low-Power-Intel-Kiste.
Weil das meiste, was das macht,
ist e-Idle den ganzen Tag.
Und die braucht halt
kaum was. Die braucht 8 Watt im Eidl.
Das ist fast so wenig
wie Raspberry Pi.
Und dafür hat die mehr Wumms und
mehr Zeug.
So, also.
Die ASI Raspberry Pi Angebote
lohnen sich nicht. Das Raspberry Pi
Angebot...
Ist da ein Netzteil dabei?
Das könnte was...
Okay, das Gehäuse
macht einen halbwegs brauchbaren Eindruck.
Wobei ich mich frage, ist da ein Lüfter drin
oder nicht? Aktivlüfter
ist doof.
Dann würde ich ihn ehrlich gesagt eher einfach so
stehen lassen, wie er ist. Am liebsten
habe ich das Clear Case. Mal gucken,
ob es das im Angebot gibt.
Das ist nicht im An...
Das ist eigentlich relativ
günstig?
Also das ist, wenn ihr mich fragt, das beste
Raspberry Pi Case.
So, das heißt, ihr braucht ein Raspberry Pi
50 Euro. Braucht, also wenn
ihr wirklich so das Rundum-Sorglos-Paket haben wollt.
Ihr kauft das Gehäuse 20 Euro,
50 Euro für ein Raspberry Pi 4,
4 Gigabyte. Und dann
noch ein Netzteil irgendwie nochmal 10 Euro
oder so obendrauf. Und dann
seid ihr quasi bei 80 Euro.
Also besser,
besser als jedes, jedes dieser
komischen, komischen Sets hier.
Das ist alles ziemlich, ziemlich
useless. Genau. Super.
Das ist nicht nur super, das ist super
rare.
Ja, okay,
eine Micro SD-Karte könnt ihr, ja.
Wobei ich ja persönlich eher
ein Fan von SSD
mit, also mit USB
auf SATA Adapter bin und dann
eine SSD. Gut, dann wird es aber
noch ein bisschen teurer. Aber ich
muss, muss ich
ich halte diese Starter-Sets
hier nicht
für so geil.
Reicht der USB vom Stromport?
Ja, also das
ist nicht, dass es läuft,
aber besser ist es mit so einem Netzteil
hier, mit so einem zum Beispiel.
Ja,
5,1 Volt, 3 Ampere, das ist im Prinzip
genau die gleichen Specks, die das offizielle
Netzteil auch hat.
Ja.
Könnt ihr gucken, nehmt
ihr das billigste. Das muss kein 5,1
Volt, ein 5 Volt tut es auch. Aber
wichtig ist, dass es ein 5 Volt, 3 Ampere Netzteil
ist, dass wenn das Ding mal wirklich ordentlich
was zieht, dass es das auch machen kann.
Die Raspberry Pi stürzen in der Regel nicht ab,
wenn das Netzteil zu klein dimensioniert ist.
Die meckern
rum, dass sie zu wenig
bekommen und
drosseln sich.
Würde auch 2,5 Zoll HDD
gehen. Klar, wenn du einen Starter auf USB
hast, geht alles. Wobei ich ganz ehrlich
in der heutigen Zeit SSD kosten nichts.
Da wünsche ich eine SSD dran
zu packen.
Ach so, das
meinst du.
Reicht der Strom vom USB
Port denn? Ja, der reicht.
Der reicht. Ich hab das selbst
laufen.
Haben wir das nicht sogar im Stream zusammen gemacht?
Wo wir das Gehäuse zusammen
gebaut haben?
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Warte mal, warte mal.
Warte mal.
Ach, schief.
Äh, case.
Das beste Raspberry Pi
Cast, das ist der Stream vom
zweiten
Februar, 11.
11. Februar.
Äh.
Welches
ist es?
Das beste Raspberry Pi Case hier.
Alter, die Musik.
MonkaS.
Ist ja gut jetzt.
What the fuck?
Übertreib halt.
Okay, jetzt ist es aber nicht sonderlich entspannend.
Genau, guck da irgendwo.
Hier, da bauen wir das Case zusammen.
Clear Case und dann irgendwann
kommt noch die SSD unten drunter.
Haben wir da nicht schon eine SSD unten
drunter gemacht?
Ich bilde mir ein, wir haben da eine
SSD noch drunter gemacht. Das war aber vielleicht
in einem anderen Stream. Ist auch wurscht.
Ja, der Strom reicht
für die SSD.
So.
Oh, was hat er die Bahn
wieder angestellt?
Nee, ich bin nicht erkält.
Die Klimaanlage, die Luft hier ist ja nur übelst trocken.
Okay.
Ich finde es immer noch geil, dass das
Apple Zeug in dem Fall
so schweineteuer ist.
Ja, okay, das Video ist schon ein bisschen her.
Ich habe dein letztes Video gesehen,
wo du über VPN-Anbieter geredet hast.
Du hast doch gesagt, dass man
sich von einem VPN selber
machen kann, ja?
Das kann man, wieviel RAM?
Das ist egal. Nimm den kleinsten.
Für VPN brauchst du nicht viel RAM.
Mal kurz hier
durchscrollen.
Ja, ich benutze
Raspberry Pi auch null für grafische Sachen.
Nee, da liege ich zu viel.
Ich habe die schon mal gezeigt, ja, aber
jetzt aktuell, wenn da alle Kameras ansehen,
liege ich zu viel.
Habe ich
noch nicht ausprobiert.
Oma, danke schön für den Zapp.
Ja,
nimm das Clear Case, das ist super.
Genau, ja.
So, okay, wunderbar. Gucken wir mal weiter.
Also das Apple-Zeug,
hat jemand von euch diese Apple-Maus
schon mal ausprobiert? Ich finde, das Ding
sieht so unergonomisch und
fragwürdig aus und es ist auch noch teuer.
Aber manchmal ist das Zeug
bei Apple ja ganz gut, auch wenn es
erst nicht so aussieht. Oder ist das
einfach nur, um besonders hip zu sein?
Übels Müll,
dachte ich mir. Das dachte ich mir.
Die hat den Ladeport unten drunter.
Die Maus ist kacke zu bedienen.
Mich würde das auch
ehrlich gesagt wundern, bei dieser
Optik, ja.
Also, wie hast du das Tablet
an der Wand montiert? Ich habe
zwei
Gegensprechanlagen-Telefone
an der Wand.
Und ich habe das zwischen
die Gegensprechanlage
und die Wand geklemmt. Da hatte ich Glück,
dass der Abstand genau groß genug war,
dass es mit ein bisschen links und rechts
was dazwischen geschoben, das
genau so breit ist wie ein HD10.
Sieht vielleicht nicht so schön aus, aber
hält fest.
So, Apple Watch kann für mich
kaum uninteressanter sein.
So, iPhone 12s Mini, wie gesagt,
iPhone 12 würde ich mir jetzt eh nicht mal kaufen.
Also, ich
erst recht nicht. Ich habe genug iPhone
Campbell hier am Start, mehr brauche ich nur wirklich nicht.
Aber, ich würde wahrscheinlich jetzt warten,
weil ich mit der Akkulaufzeit
von dem 12er, was ich gelesen habe, nicht so zufrieden
war. Die wollen den Kram...
Das sieht für mich so aus, als wollen sie den Kram
loswerden, bis die im
September neues Zeug vorstellen.
Was kostet es denn bei... Ne,
Apple.de müssen wir, ne?
Was kostet es denn offiziell bei Apple?
Kaufen.
Auf Apple, please.
Seite. Mach hinne.
Achtung, Flashbang.
Das ist ich, blau.
Ok, das kostet tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr.
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich würde mir trotzdem keins kaufen jetzt.
So, Apple Watch juckt mich nicht.
Noch mehr Apple Watch, noch mehr iPhone 12.
Apple Watch, iPhone 12,
Apple Watch, iPhone 12.
Ist den eigentlich klar,
dass es auch auf Amazon
Farbauswahl gibt, dass man nicht 100
Produkte reinstellen muss, sondern einfach
Farbe und Band
auswählbar machen kann?
Oder ist das Apple nicht...
Ist das denen nicht agil genug zu?
Apple Watch, iPhone 12,
iPhone 12.
iPhone 12, Apple Watch. What the fuck?
Haben die sonst noch irgendwas... Ah, ok,
iPad. Boah, die Dinger sind
auch teurer. Ich habe mir mal kurzzeitig
überlegt, ob ich mir ein iPad Pro kaufen soll,
aber es war es mir nicht wert,
den Aufpreis zu bezahlen, nur
für Face ID.
Ok, das lohnt sich aber überhaupt gar nicht.
Useless AF.
Oh, guck mal.
Ist das der Bild... Ah, nee, das ist der iMac.
Ich dachte, das ist der Bildschirm,
wo allein schon die Halterung
400 Euro kostet.
Nee, 1000 Euro.
Wie viel kostete die Halterung nochmal?
Nee, die Halterung kostet 1000, ne?
Die Halterung kostet 1000?
Ja, genau. Und der VESA-Mount
kostete irgendwie nochmal 300 oder so.
Ja, Apple ist da teilweise schon
so ein bisschen detached von der Realität.
Also, die Musik ist mir gerade
zu anstrengend.
Muss mal was anderes anmachen.
Ja, viel besser.
Paper Jam.
So, also alles useless.
Was gibt es denn sonst immer noch interessantes?
Sowas wie Werkzeuge,
zum Beispiel...
Smart Home. Wir gucken jetzt mal Smart Home.
Was gibt es Smart Home?
Wahrscheinlich auch nur Müll, aber schauen wir mal schnell.
Warum ist ein Kühlschrank
und eine Waschmaschine unter Smart Home?
Das ist ein WLAN-Kühlschrank.
Was ist an denen sonderlich smart?
Sehen ehrlich gesagt aus wie
halt Waschmaschine.
Wie Waschmaschinen so aussehen.
Was würdest du für 50 Euro empfehlen?
Hol dann Fire HD 8 und Flash selbst.
Falls du ein Tablet brauchst,
was einfach irgendwo rum liegt und
du ab und zu mal drauf drückst.
Best of Smart Home.
Na dann zeig mal her.
Leute, haltet euch fest. Jetzt kommen die
besten Smart Home Sachen.
Smart Lock. Fängt ja schon lustig,
fängt ja schon geil an.
Das einzige Smart Home Gadget,
was ich mir im Leben nicht holen werde,
ist ein Smart Lock.
Mechanischer Gong.
Krass, krass. Das ist ja aber wirklich
Next Level Smart Home.
Ein Gong. Da hab ich drauf gewartet,
dass ich Best of Smart Home krieg.
Door-Window-Kontakt-Sensor.
Viel, viel, viel zu teuer.
Auch kein Mensch.
E-Switch-Kamera.
Keine Ahnung, ob die was taucht.
Also, wenn das Best of Smart Home
sein soll, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Biersteckdosen für 111 Euro.
What the fuck?
111 Euro sind die noch,
sind die noch
bei Sinnen?
Bei AliExpress kriegste für 25 Euro
ein Viererpack.
Nee, 111 Euro ist wirklich
richtig, richtig hart.
Was würdest du für ein
24-7-Ur-Wachungssystem empfehlen?
Gar keins, weil ich hab keins.
Was ich habe ist, ich hab ein paar billige
Cams,
die unter anderem auch für
Außeneinsatz als wasserdicht sind.
Und ich hab mir selbst was zusammengebastelt,
dass ich mir die Dinger im
Browser anzeigen lassen kann. Fertig.
Also, ich nehm nix auf.
Ich mach auch keine Motion-Erkennung so wirklich.
Ich mach nix. Ich guck einfach immer nur drauf.
Zum Beispiel, eine Sache, wofür
ich benutze ist halt, wenn's klingelt,
dann geht auf dem Tablet im Flur, geht
die Kamera auf und zeigt die Kamera
an, geht der Browser auf
und zeigt die Kamera an von
der Tür. Ja, sowas.
Aber ich nehm da nix auf.
Hast du denn Amazon
Affiliate Link? Ja, hab ich. Aber hab ich grad
nicht da.
Kann grad kein Sellout machen, ich weiß.
Paints Champing.
Jetzt wollen die Leute schon Geld ausgeben und können nicht,
aber ich kenn mein Ref.
Auf Twitter hab ich mein Ref-Link.
Leute, auf Twitter.
Twitter hab ich mein Ref-Link. Guck mal hier.
Massive,
also wenn ihr was kaufen wollt, könnt
ihr einfach über mein Ref-Link gehen hier.
Worauf hab ich denn da
eigentlich verlinkt? PS4,
Alter, wie alt ist denn der Link
noch?
Wie alt ist denn der Link
immer im Twitter-Profil?
Letztendlich ist aber auch egal, weil
wenn man über diesen Link auf
Amazon draufgeht und selbst wenn man nichts
hier von kauft, alles was ihr kauft
in den nächsten 48 Stunden, solange
ihr nicht danach einen anderen Ref-Link anklickt,
krieg ich was von ab.
Und es kostet euch nicht mehr,
also wenn's euch danach
ist, dann hab ich da, ja, fänd ich
natürlich nicht schlecht. So,
also wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Best of.
Was hatte die Build damit
zu tun? Howmatic IP Build
Edition, ja genau, das ist, das ist,
wär das für euch nicht auch der Kaufgrund
schlechthin?
Es schwankt, wie viel du bekommst bei Amazon.
Unsinnig, viel zu teuer.
Brauchen wir nicht. Sackt wahrscheinlich
richtig, kenn ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich
sackts.
Die Kameras sind nicht
so sonderlich nice, die hatte ich mir auch mal
angeguckt.
Me, it's witz.
Das war jetzt, ah jetzt geht noch mal
ein bisschen weiter, das war jetzt best
Smartphone oder was?
Unreal, danke schön für vier Monate Subscription.
Alles, alles so useless
Kram, ey.
Was ist das denn?
Warum sieht
ihr denn aus wie irgendwie einen Radar?
Das sieht
aus wie so ein Radar auf dem Schiff.
Ach, weil es im Flutlicht
drinnen ist, okay. Übrigens diese
diese Einbrecherbilder auf den Kamerasachen
sind immer so geil.
Genauso sieht es als Einbrecher dann aus,
wenn er sich fotografieren lässt.
Auch keiner
eine Klingel.
Wahnsinnig geiles Smart Home Gadget.
Ah, so viel, so viel
unbrauchbarer Krämpel.
Ein Bewegungsmelder für
21,99.
Ist der, ist, ist, ist, ist da, ist,
ist da innen Gold oder wie?
Da vergoldet.
Okay, die Dinger sind nicht schlecht.
Tatsächlich immer was Gutes dabei, allerdings finde
ich die Candle-Dinger nicht so praktisch.
Ähm, die
Liveaxe-Dinger sind wirklich, das finde
ich, aber nicht die,
mit die besten
RGB-Lampen.
Mal gucken, ob es da bei Amazon
Prime der was gibt.
Boah, die sind ja immer noch ultra
teuer, wenn du sie hier kaufst, meine
Güte. Ah, das ist ein Zweierpack, das ist okay.
Zweierpack, das sind die,
Moment.
Weiß?
Nee, ich will die nicht in Weiß.
Ich will die zumindest, zumindest
mit, mit, äh, Weiß,
also zumindest mit, ähm,
Pub-Temperatur.
Ich glaube, das ist
die rein, nee, das sackt.
Es gibt
Ausrufezeichen Amazon. Ja,
Wahnsinn, die Mods wird da richtig
Big Brain hier am Start gewesen.
Also, nur in
Weiß ist natürlich jetzt nicht so geil.
Also, es gibt ja, es gibt ja
LED-Lampen in, in, in verschiedenen
Ausführungen. Die, die einfachste Variante
ist meistens Weiß
und DIMBA.
Das heißt, du hast da halt, ähm,
im Prinzip eine LED-Farbe drin.
Und das ist DIMBA.
Das nächste ist Weiß,
allerdings mit Farbtemperatureinstellung.
Da ist dann wahrscheinlich eine Weiße
und eine Rote LED drinne, weil du kannst
halt Farbtemperatur einstellen, von
bläulich zu rötlich.
DIMBA. Und das nächste
ist dann wirklich RGB.
Und ich sag immer, dass man normalerweise
gar kein RGB braucht,
aber
nur Weiß ist auch doof.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute werden am glücklichsten
mit, ähm,
Smart, Smart-Lampen, die
Weiß mit
Farbtemperatur-Einstellung sind.
So.
Aber das ist nur Weiß
und ich glaub, ohne, ohne...
Ja, was jetzt? Color?
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Weil, ja, was ist es denn jetzt?
Ich glaub, die können sich nicht so genau
entscheiden, ob das jetzt die RGB-Lampe ist
oder in Weiß.
Farbrauchschuhe. Ok, das ist die
RGB-Variante. Dann ist der Preis
wirklich ok. Zweierpack.
Zweierpack für
55 Euro, das ist in Ordnung.
Wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, das sind die besten RGB-Lampen,
die es gibt. Die
LIFX-Dinger, die sind wirklich nice.
Hab ich auch
einige.
Ja, Weiß ist nur das Plastik.
Das ist halt ein wenig, ich weiß nicht,
irgendwie trotzdem ein bisschen missverständlich geschrieben.
Aber klar, LIFX-Color könnte man sagen,
ja, ist schon so. Hätten die noch
RGB reingeschrieben, dann wäre klar gewesen.
Brauchen wir für die eine
Zigbee Bridge? Nein, die sind komplett WLAN.
Das bin ich tatsächlich am
Überlegen, ob ich mir das jetzt nicht einfach kaufe.
Auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Weil, das ist echt nicht
verkehrt.
Zack, ich muss mal kurz
eine Runde
auf dem Handy den Kram
ordern, weil ich bin nicht eingeloggt
auf dem zweiten Browser. Mit eigenem RefLink?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Leider,
leider kann man den eigenen RefLink nicht
für sich
selbst verwenden.
Also, wenn du an die Adresse schickst,
wo derjenige wohnt,
auf den der RefLink registriert ist,
kannst du deinen RefLink nicht verwenden.
Ansonsten kannst du dir ja quasi alles selbst
über deinen eigenen RefLink bestellen.
Was ja eigentlich auch nicht so schlimm wäre.
Ich meine, Amazon verdient damit
immer noch ordentlich.
Okay,
Best of, Best of, wir sind immer noch bei Best of,
nee, Moment, Best of. Wo war
Best of Smart Home? Wo sind wir stehen geblieben, Leute? Wo war?
Best of,
Best of Smart Home.
Ist es weg?
Wo ist Best of Smart Home?
Best of Smart Home.
Wir waren auf Seite 2, glaube ich.
Jetzt gehen wir jetzt schnell drüber,
da ist nur Müll dabei.
Ja, genau.
Also, die kann man echt empfehlen.
Die sind nice. Braucht man alles nicht.
Useless,
useless, useless.
Was ist denn das für ein hässliches Ding?
Sieht aus wie so,
wie so eine
Biene oder so.
Ah.
Useless, useless,
useless,
useless, useless.
Next.
Alles useless.
Was ist das für ein Anschluss?
Sieht nicht aus wie ein deutscher Anschluss.
Useless,
useless, useless, useless.
Alles
sinnlos.
Braucht kein Mensch. Bam, zu, weg damit.
So, was haben die sonst
immer noch schönes zu bieten?
Wann kommt ein neues Video, sobald
ich ein neues Video aufnehme?
Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht
morgen schon. Vielleicht mache ich
wirklich das Apple vs. Linux vs.
Windows Video mal. Hab ich jetzt schon eine
Weile mich vorgedrückt.
Okay, das ist alles mega
langweilig gewesen.
Auch
komplett
langweilig, braucht kein
Mensch.
Braucht auch, braucht auch,
wie das war's? Okay.
Also, Smart, Smart Home
ist total uninteressant. Wir schauen
mal, was sagt denn, was sagt dann Heise?
Hat Heise irgendwie Prime Day Empfehlung?
Prime?
Deals und Angebote im Schnäppchencheck.
Dann mach mal.
Was, was gibt's denn hier für
Angebote?
Moment, das ist nicht...
Keg-Wade, was ist das?
Ah, ich wurde redirected zu
einem anderen Angebot von dem
G-Baded.
Also, was
haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Das ist ja die billigste
Linksammlung überhaupt.
Lull.
Okay, das ist schlecht.
Das guck ich mir nicht an. Dann kann ich es mir auch
bei Amazon direkt angucken.
Okay, was haben wir denn
für Werkzeuge diesmal?
Werkzeuge sind manchmal auch ganz praktisch.
Also, interessiert mich nicht.
Interessiert mich auch
alles nicht.
Vitamine und Nahrung, Ergänzungsmittel.
Ja, klar.
Da bin ich genau der Richtige für
Computer, Tablets und Zubehör.
Okay, da kann was Sinnvolles drin sein, aber erst mal
musst du so viel Müll wegräumen, dass du
wahrscheinlich das nicht findest.
Okay, da könnte was Sinnvolles
dabei sein.
Gutes Werkzeug
kann man nie genug haben.
Ne.
SSDs, vielleicht,
vielleicht.
Wisch- und Saugroboter.
Ich klick das nicht an,
weil sonst lass ich mich wieder jebaiten, da irgendwas
zu kaufen für 800 Euro. Mach ich nicht.
Diesmal nicht.
So, das
haben wir schon alles gesehen.
Akku und
Stabstaubsauger.
Die Bosch Noob Serie.
Noch mehr
China-Chinesen-Smart Home
Zeug.
Nein, ich guck mir keine
167 Seiten an, das könnt ihr vergessen.
Okay, also Computer und...
Wie sieht das...
Außer, dass es
RGB hat, sieht das irgendwie billig aus.
Okay, was gibt's denn an
Werkzeugen Schönes?
7 Volt Akkuschraubers.
Ach guck mal, ist das der gleiche, den ich auch hab?
Ich glaub schon.
Ist das der mit Schlagbohrfunktion
oder der ohne Schlagbohrfunktion?
Ich glaub, das ist der ohne Schlagbohrfunktion.
Dann ist es genau der, den
ich auch hab.
Ja, das ist der ohne.
Ja, der ist nice.
Den kann man
sich echt kaufen.
Hast doch
ein schönes Set an Sachen dabei, wenn man
keine Bohrer hat.
Ist wirklich nice, kann man
sich nicht beschweren.
Und für den Hausgebrauch
macht das einfach alles, was man so
braucht.
Dafür hast du zwei Akkus hier dabei.
Also den hab ich jetzt
schon seit zwei Jahren oder so.
Ist wirklich nice, das Teil.
So, da gibt's was noch.
Kreuzlinien,
braucht doch, brauch ich net.
Ah, das ist jetzt der
mit Schlagbohrfunktion, okay.
Ja gut, wenn einem das wichtig ist, dann kann man den
auch mit Schlagbohrfunktion nehmen.
Ich brauch keine Schlagbohrfunktion im
Akkuschrauber.
Man macht den vielleicht noch ein bisschen
multifunktioneller, okay.
Dafür aber auch ein bisschen länger.
Da hier ist eine ganze Ecke
kürzer.
Da gibt's eine Gepleese.
So was könnte ich tatsächlich gebrauchen.
So was
könnte ich tatsächlich gebrauchen.
Einfach mal zum Dreck wegblasen.
Dass man das auf der Baustelle nicht brauchen kann,
kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber für daheim
reicht das. Aber übrigens Schrauben
in die Wand und so geht damit auch.
Also Loch in die Wand, Dübel rein
und so geht damit auch.
Hat der auch eine Saugfunktion?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Manche haben was, wo du Beutel dran machen kannst.
Aber der hier sieht mir so aus, als kann er nur blasen.
Nee, ich glaube
der saugt nicht.
Dafür gibt es hier
das Trockensauger-Set.
So was könnte ich aber ernsthaft
so was könnte ich wirklich gebrauchen.
So ein Puster.
Maulschlüsselsatz,
den brauche ich nicht.
Da habe ich mal ein Vera-Set.
Richtig Poggers.
Da brauche ich nichts anderes.
So, da gibt es Schleiferkram,
den brauche ich nicht.
Sägen brauche ich auch nicht.
Schlagbohrmaschine brauche ich jetzt auch keine.
Brauche ich alles nicht. Brauche ich alles nicht.
Kreissäge, nein, brauche ich nicht.
Das ist auch keine Kreissäge,
das ist eine Kapp- und Gehrungssäge.
Muss man ja korrekt sein.
Das ist ein
Poggers.
Äh, das habe ich,
das ist cool.
Gerade mit, das kann man hier oben ausklappen.
Also man kann es entweder hinstellen
oder man kann es hier oben an so einen,
an so einen, ähm,
an Haken.
Das Ding ist richtig hell.
Funktioniert mit den gleichen 12 Akkus,
12 Volt-Akkus wie der Akkuschrauber.
Finde ich äußerst praktisch.
Gerade wenn man im Keller oder so was machen muss.
Und das ist auch ordentlich,
das ist auch ordentlich hell, das Ding.
Das ist sogar, wenn man draußen
im Hof ist und leuchtet damit auf,
also im Freien und das ist
am Tag und du leuchtest
auf dem Boden, dann siehst du das immer noch.
Also das ist doch relativ hell das Teil.
Das kann ich nur empfehlen, das ist wirklich cooles Licht.
Vor allem wenn man eh schon 12 Volt-Akkus von Bosch hat,
dann ist es sehr praktisch.
Entfernungsmesser, da habe ich schon einen.
Brauche ich nicht.
Das ist die Flexi,
Flexi-Click-Variante.
Oder Flex-Click,
Flexi-Click, ich weiß nicht wie es heißt,
aber da wo du unterschiedliche
Aufsätze drauf machen kannst, ist auf jeden Fall ein cooles Ding.
Aber brauche ich auch nicht.
Eisluft habe ich eine andere.
Ne.
Ach ja, einen Schnapper.
641 Euro für die Wärmebildkamera.
Easy.
Ich meine, wenn man es braucht, dann ist es cool, wenn man es hat.
Aber ich fände es nice,
aber ich wüsste beim besten Willen nicht,
wofür ich es brauchen würde.
Also zumindest nicht
so oft brauchen würde, dass 641 Euro
gerechtfertigt sind.
Hat auch eine Durchblickfunktion.
Also ich muss sagen,
mein Auge hat auch eine Durchblickfunktion.
Da brauche ich das eigentlich nicht.
Okay, ziemlich useless
für mich alles.
Außer der Bläser vielleicht.
Was ist deiner Meinung nach der beste Virenscanner?
Einfach Windows Defender behalten
und nichts zusätzlich installieren.
Fertig aus.
Immer wieder die gleichen SSDs im Angebot.
Das gefühlt auch jedes Jahr
das gleiche, ne.
Aber bei SSDs ist es halt
so ähnlich wie bei RAM.
Du kannst eigentlich nie genug SSDs haben.
Die waren die letzten drei Jahre schon im Angebot.
Diese Tinger.
Davon habe ich auch ein paar.
Aber mehr brauche ich beim besten Willen nicht.
Also ich habe echt genug SSDs.
Was ich krass finde, wie billig das
geworden ist, ne.
Ich habe mir eine 2...
Ey, das ist richtiger Painschamp.
Ich habe mir eine 2 Terabyte
SSD gekauft, als das neu war,
das Zeug, für ich glaube 700
Euro.
Da war das das größte, was es gegeben
hat. Und jetzt kostet es 169.
Easy Money, easy life.
Ja, das ist auch schon 4 Jahre oder so her.
Aber das war halt teuer.
Jaja, 700 Euro.
Ich kann nachkommen.
Ich gucke mal auf dem Handy nach, was es gekostet hat.
Das Handy ist das einzige, wo ich gerade Amazon
eingeloggt bin. Your orders.
Oh, Amazon ist überlastet.
Amazon ist überlastet.
Samsung.
Also Samsung Endurance.
Hier.
2015 habe ich die gekauft.
850 Evo.
Und hat gekostet
699 Euro.
2 Terabyte.
Vor 6 Jahren.
Und jetzt kostet es 269 Euro.
RIP.
Gut, das war aber klar.
Das war aber klar.
Aber ob ich das jemals wegstärken werde, weiß
ich nicht. Also ich glaube, da brauche
ich ein paar Prime-Sub, dass ich da
drüber wegkomme.
Passt richtig thematisch, richtig gut.
Danke für den Prime-Sub.
5-Hat-Subscription-Zeit hier. Richtiges Timing.
So.
Ich glaube aber, dass der Preis tatsächlich
ganz gut ist. Ich habe jetzt keinen
Vergleich, aber wenn man...
Letztendlich SSD-Speicher kannst du
nie genug haben.
Genau. Und außerdem habe ich das Ding
jetzt schon 6 Jahre. Deswegen, das
lohnt sich nicht. Man muss jetzt zum aktuellen
Zeitpunkt gucken, ob man das braucht und
dann kaufen.
Zum Glück brauche ich aktuell keine
Grafikkarte, weil dann hätte ich
echt gelitten.
20 Rico.
Richtig geil jebaiten lassen zum Subscriben.
4 Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, unsinnig. Brauche
alles nett.
Gut, halt SSDs. Wer SSDs
braucht, kann sich am Prime-Play immer
SSDs kaufen. Das schadet nichts.
Wo hat einer gesagt? Soll ich mal gucken
bei MyDeals? Haben die da
irgendwelche...
MyDeals mag ich. Die haben den Preis-Champ
empfohlen. In den Kommentaren irgendwann mal.
520 Kabelbinder.
Jawoll.
399 Poggers.
Da warte ich mein ganzes Leben lang auf das
Angebot schon.
Haben die irgendwas zu Prime?
Day?
Nein.
Amazon Prime
der Angebot ist wahrscheinlich auch total
langweilig. Firestick
juckt keinen.
Interessiert nicht.
Warehouse schon geguckt? Ne.
Das können wir aber
tatsächlich mal machen.
So unübersichtlich.
Warehouse können wir tatsächlich mal gucken.
Was muss denn da gucken?
Wie finde ich
das?
Du musst den Preis-Champ fixen.
Die Preise sind viel zu hoch.
Ja, das liegt ja auch am Preis-Champ.
Handmade
Produkte.
Also was
könnte mich denn jetzt hier vor noch interessieren?
Werkzeuge hatten wir auch schon.
Warehouse Deals.
Der Chat ist mal einfach wieder
zu Elevenhead.
Der weiß einfach Bescheid.
30%
Ausgelbte Produkte.
Exklusiv
Moment, das ist doch wieder
ist das jetzt was anderes?
Das ist doch genau das
Amazon
Warehouse Events.
Das ist wieder
also ich blick da langsam, ich blick nicht
mehr durch, das ist mir zu
hoch.
Das ist doch wieder genau der gleiche Kram, nur dass die Seite
jetzt anders aussieht.
Staubsauger und Bogenflieger.
Da muss ich mal gucken, da bräuchte ich wirklich so einen neuen
Sauger. Gucken ob es da so was
gibt. So was da.
Weil manchmal,
aber das habe ich das Problem,
dass eben in der Werkstatt im
Hof, also
das ist noch so eine alte Werkstatt, da wo der
Opa seine Werkstatt drin hat, da regnet es manchmal
rein, wenn es zu sehr regnet.
Und da brauche ich so einen Sauger, um das Wasser
wieder rauszusaugen.
Und den Sauger, den ich jetzt habe, der macht es nicht
mehr lange.
Wobei, nichts dabei.
Okay, wie finde ich denn jetzt wirklich noch sinnvolle
Amazon Angebote?
Das ist jedes Mal so.
Es ist so unglaublich unübersichtlich
und so voller
Müll zum größten Teil, dass du echt
keine Ahnung hast, wo du eigentlich anfangen sollst.
Also,
ich glaube,
das ist jetzt
so ein bisschen
unabhängig.
Wo soll ich anfangen?
Ich bleche dann überhaupt nicht mehr durch.
Anker.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Bügeleisen.
Okay, ich habe eine Idee.
Blitzangebote.
Ist da irgendwas interessantes dabei?
Lightning-Kabel.
Okay, das ist ja richtig
useless.
Das ist ja richtig useless.
Damenarmband, alles klar.
USB-C.
Disco-Kugel-LED-Party-Lampe.
Warum ist das 85% eingelöst?
Wer kauft sowas und warum?
Wer kauft das?
Was ist der Hintergedanken?
Also, was muss einem durch den Kopf gehen,
dass man sich dafür entschließt, das zu kaufen?
Das ist voll cool.
Das ist eben so ein kleines Mini-Ding,
was noch nicht mal den Raum
irgendwie ansatzweise
beleuchten kann.
Du willst eine für die Toilette kaufen?
Okay, ja, das leuchtet mir ein.
Okay, weiter.
Braucht man alles nicht.
Braucht man nicht irgendwelche komischen
Lichterketten.
Einfach komplett random hier alles
zusammengewürfelt.
WLAN-Outdoor-Steckdose.
Kann man die flaschen?
Wenn man die flaschen kann, wäre das
tatsächlich gar nicht so verkehrt.
IP44 ist überhaupt nicht
wasserdicht.
IP44 ist doch mal mit
Ach und Krach
am Dach bei regendicht, oder?
Oder bin ich da?
IP-Schutzklasse, genau.
Das hasse ich, dieses Aufploppen.
Geht das noch einem, dass ihr manchmal
wo draufklicken wollt und dann ploppt
in dem Moment was anderes auf und ihr kriegt das Falsche an?
Das nervt mich immer.
Schutz, Schutz, Schutzart hier.
Genau.
So, Kennziffer.
Das ist Staub.
So und das ist Wasser.
4. Schutz gegen allseitige Spritzwasser.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
ich kann das an die Wand hängen und
unterm Dach, wenn es dann regnet, ist okay.
Aber direkt, direkt
in starken Regen kann ich das auch nicht hängen.
Okay, kann man die Dinger flaschen?
Wenn man die Dinger flaschen kann, wäre das
wahrscheinlich doch nicht so schlecht.
Was ist denn das für ein, steht da irgendwie
was drauf, was das ist?
Weil der Hersteller sagt einem, das bringt
nichts, um nach Flaschen zu, ich guck mal.
Ich, ich, ich such mal,
ob's die, ob's die hier in der Geräte
Datenband gibt.
Powerstrip, Powerstrip.
Nee, nein.
Outdoor.
Passmotor.
Aha.
WLAN Outdoor Steckdose.
2 Channels mit Passmotor flaschen.
Ist das die?
Äh.
Kann er, kann er das Teil vielleicht mal ordentlich?
Nee, das ist eine andere.
Das ist eine andere.
Is der Kindle Paper White noch flashbar?
Kein Schimmer.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal von ausgehen, man kann sie wahrscheinlich
flaschen, aber so genau
weiß man das nicht.
Kauf's einfach und find's heraus.
Nee.
Selbst wenn es so 26 Euro sind. Ich könnte mal in den
Comments gucken, ob da irgendwie einer was von, von
Flaschen reingeschrieben hat.
Das.
Okay.
Flash.
Kein TAS-Motor möglich.
Ja.
Ach, der verbaute WLAN-Chip ist kein ESP-
86.
Okay, dann, dann RIP.
RIP.
Dann kann man's nicht flashen.
Dann lohnt sich das für mich überhaupt nicht.
MediaTek-Chip? Nee, dann ist
vorbei.
Ich hab schon mal den Fehler gemacht,
von denen, äh, was zu kaufen und dann
ging's auch nicht zu flashen.
So, was haben wir hier
sonst noch Schönes?
Noch mehr USB-Kabel.
Noch mehr
RGB-Lampen, die ich nicht brauche.
Was zum, es gibt so viel Schrott.
Es gibt so viel Schrott
einfach nur.
Das Ding sieht nicht sonderlich, äh,
stabil und, und
wie soll, wie soll man sagen?
Sonderlich sicher aus.
Das ist bestimmt China-Chinesen-
Zeug, oder?
Ja, oh, guck mal, das ist ein
CE-Zeichen drauf. Das ist natürlich bei
Chinasachen. Das ist garantiert ein China,
China-Chinesen-Ding.
Aoglet.
Ah. Ah, nee.
Aogled.
GLED.
Das ist China.
Das ist China-Kram.
Naja.
Die Dinger sind garantiert,
äh, nicht
sonderlich robust
und safe.
Ey, das sieht fast ein bisschen aus
wie Chico, guck mal.
Wo hat er ein Bild von meiner Katz?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Das ist so eine
ganz andere Katz. Warum ist das hier eine
andere Katz als auf dem Bild?
Anzeige ist raus.
Guck mal. Chibated.
Hier ist es eine
rote, äh, so eine orange-rote
Katze und hier ist es eine
gefleckte.
Katzen-Chibate.
Weil das sieht wirklich ein bisschen aus
wie Chico.
Clickbait 100.
Mit SR-Entferner-Set.
Es gibt so paar Dinger.
Bin ich froh, dass ich die dann brauche.
HDMI-Kabel.
HDMI-Kabel. 4K.
Wie viele Selle Gummi?
Eins muss man
den ja mal lassen. Der Kram ist schon
wirklich hardcore random.
Ich mein, kleiner Freund,
Kinderrucksack, äh,
dann irgendwie
Wagenheber,
dann USB-Kabel
und danach irgendwelche Schutzfolie
für Apple Watch. Das ist schon
maximal verwirrend.
Musst du heute nicht arbeiten? Nein, ich muss
montags zum Glück nie arbeiten.
Richtig.
Montags arbeiten nur die Noobs.
Homeoffice-Regeln, da kann man immer hier
schauen. Ja, das ist es. Das ist gut.
Was ein Leben. Naja, ich bekomme auch weniger Geld
deswegen. Also ich bekomme ja nur dann 80%
wenn ich nach weniger arbeite.
Aber ist mir so lieber.
Weil was hat man von so viel gearbeite?
Also wenn die Kohle ausreicht, warum soll ich
mehr arbeiten, als dass die Kohle ausreicht?
Was benutzt du für ein Betriebssystem?
Ich habe Windows unten drunter
und das ist eine VM mit Manjaro
Linux.
Taschenwaage,
Mikrofaser,
Handtücher.
Was ein Kram, Alter.
Wer braucht denn den ganzen
Mist? Handtuchhaken.
Was ist denn das?
Eine Leselampe.
Hä? Ach, das
macht man sich um den Hals oder was?
Das macht man sich um den Hals und dann
scheint das da...
Leuchtet er
allen Ernstes auf sein Tablet?
Leuchtet...
Die Chinesen,
die Chinesen,
die schrecken wirklich
von links zurück.
Aufs Tablet.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Das ist wieder
was ein Werbebild, Alter.
Kann man das nicht?
Kann man das nicht irgendwie aufmachen?
Das muss ich mir speichern, das Bild.
Es ist auch
definitiv
nicht Photoshopped.
Niemals ist das
Photoshopped.
Unglaublich.
Unglaublich der ganze Müll.
Okay, was
haben wir sonst noch?
Was ist das
überhaupt?
Das ist Fick Fu-fup.
Was?
Okay, das ist irgendwas zum Rohr
reinigen oder so?
Klobürste?
Junge Startup.
Ahh, das ist die
Felgenreinigung.
Okay, das könnte ich jetzt
der überschrift nicht erkennt also ich meine wer ist auf die glorreiche idee gekommen dass das
heißt und man da auf die idee kommen soll dass es eine felgen reinigungspürste ist
schon was nice ist gefunden
ja rgb lampe aber das war es aber auch
das ist auch was was ich unbedingt brauche aber für den preis 2 2 2
55 euro ganz ok ist weil das eben auch grad die sind die ich sonst auch verwende
ok useless
Ach das ist neq wie plek filament brauche ich nicht ich habe noch genug filament
Hula hoop reifen genau das richtige für mich meint ihr der bauch ist photoshopped
ist immer schwer zu sagen bei diesen bildern aber der bauch könnte durchaus photoshopped sein
Welche drucke hast du ich habe ein anycubic 3d anycubic i3 mega s so rum
Dann haben wir hier ein
Es gibt so unglaublich viel müll
switch ladestation
Ja es ist ja immer noch ein moment
Das ist doch im prinzip gar kein großer unterschied zum original oder
Funktioniert der original controller nicht ganz genauso
Dass du das anschließt und dann letzt die joycons
Warum brauche ich eine extra station
Und verstehe verstehe ich jetzt einfach nur nicht
Das originale kann man nicht wirklich
Ich habe drüben ein stehen ich könnte wetten da ist da hätte man drüber laden können stimmt das original ja ihr habt recht klar
Das original ist nur ein blasist um ab wie lange ich keine switch mal verwendet haben verwendet hab
Ja warum man das nicht laden kann habe ich nicht verstanden
Moby cool elektrische kompressor kühle wisst ihr was ich dachte ich dachte so ein transport box für kreative kühle
Aber das ist es nicht das ist eine kompressor kühlbox
Das ist ganz viel
Wie viel useless kram es hier gibt
isolierte edelstahl trinkfleische schach bretter
Ich soll mir so ein mehr jungen frauenschwanz holen ja ich ich habe auch kurz mit dem gedanken gespielt
Ich glaube so ein mehr jungen frauenschwanz wäre schon nicht schlecht
Hier für die rolex sammlung erst mal 15 euro koffer kaufen
Die dinger sind tatsächlich ganz praktisch da kann man so durchmesser von von löchern und so messen ich glaube sowas war das
Aber bestimmt ist das nicht sonderlich präzise für 1599 von den chinesischen china verwendet
auf amazon
jamm jamm premium nassfutter ob das schicko schmeckt
jamm jamm
Ja klar ist klar natürlich natürlich
Mit sicherheit mit sicherheit ist es nicht so präzise
Mit sicherheit mit sicherheit ist das da drin
Dankeschön players unknown prime prime gaming
Subscription huge
Jaja ist klar ist ist klar ist klar ist klar nur nur vom pfeil ist drin
Wobei mir haben ist glaube ich wirklich gutes zeug ganz ohne getreide extra hoher fleischenteil aber
Also das dürfte man ja doch ein bisschen übertrieben sein
Es gibt nix es gibt so viel müll es gibt einfach so viel mit hdmi vga adapter
Alles klar bin ich froh dass ich schon ewig kein vga mehr anschließen musste
So
Madias und john energy haben subscrib danken für den sub leute
Ja mir haben es echt nicht verkehrt nee ich weiß das ist ist kein schlechtes katzfutter
Es ist ein löffel einfach
Was wäsche säcke es also
Gibt es wirklich leute die sich da jetzt 127 167 seiten angucken
Und und dann irgendwie auf seite 105 was sagen boah geil das habe ich schon immer mal gesucht
Echt wirklich also chat chat jetzt gebetet mich jetzt oder
Ne ich konnte mir nicht so viel an ich bin ich bin kurz davor zu sagen
Ich gehe auf
Das nee das ist das ist ja so so ein unglaublich hoher anteil an müll
Ich habe da gar keinen bock mich da durch zu die dinger sind übrigens sehr cool
japan segen
Aber die weiß ich jetzt nicht aber die art und weise ist cool
Garten sägestell
Hey chris an die wey way crisp nicht hey chris
Leute ich kann nicht die seiten ich muss ich muss jetzt irgendwie mal das kategorien technisch
Machen hier hier findet ihr hier findet ihr nix das nähset jawoll
Okay, welche kategorie ich mache mal alles zu außer des priming so welche kategorie könnte mich denn davor noch interessieren
Also wir haben jetzt amazon gerät anguckt computer also ssd stellz haben wir uns angeguckt smarttom haben wir uns angeguckt
Ansonsten ansonsten interessiert mich eigentlich
Vielleicht was für chico dabei vielleicht vielleicht gibt es was geiles für chico zeigt mal
Aber haben wir was tolles für chico
Was hat dann das bitteschön mit haustier bedarf zu tun das ne mütz
Zieh doch mal in der katz keine bommelmütze
Das ist wahrscheinlich dass man besser gassi gehen kann
Ich habe auch noch ein bisschen was zu tun
Also wenn ich chico sowas hinlege die hat der angst davor
Chico hat vor allem schiss wenn da auf einmal sowas im flur liegt da geht die nicht mehr in den flur
Sowas habe ich im wohnzimmer allerdings nicht so als hängematte
Sondern so als brett was man an an die fenster fensterbank machen kann das mag sie da liegt sie immer
abends rum der hund ist definitiv nicht rein photoshopped leute legit
Alter was ist das für monkaS musik
Huge monkaS musik
Happy kirby musik jawoll
Okay haustiere bedarf auch nix dabei
Baby bedarf brauche ich zum glück nicht und ich hoffe auch nicht dass ich das bequem werde
Babybedarf brauche ich zum Glück nicht und ich hoffe auch nicht, dass ich das brauche irgendwann mal.
Kopfhörer und Lautsprecher.
Es ist so langweilig, es gibt nichts und wenn, dann ist es so unübersichtlich.
Ich habe gar keinen Bock mehr weiter zu gucken ehrlich gesagt.
Alle Angebote.
Ich gehe jetzt, wir machen es jetzt anders.
Wir müssen Amazon outplayen.
Die rechnen damit, dass man total überfordert ist.
Was wir jetzt machen ist, wir gehen einfach auf Seite 100.
Ne, warte mal.
Random Org.
Ich brauche eine random number.
Zwischen 100 und zwischen 1 und 167.
Okay, get numbers.
Okay, 33.
Seite 33.
Wir outplayen Amazon jetzt mit random generator.
Seite 133.
Wie komme ich dahin?
Pianza, kann man nicht direkt auf irgendeine Seite springen?
Anscheinend, anscheinend.
Omi wie Seite 8.
In der UL finde ich aber die Seitennummer nicht.
Was davon ist Seitennummer?
Amazon hat random generator outplayed.
Sieht fast so aus.
Okay.
Amazon jump to side to page number.
How to skip from page 100.
Was, da steht page drin?
Ne, das steht da mittlerweile.
Das ist von 2015, das steht da nicht mal.
Hier steht nichts mehr von page drin.
Ich meine, wir sind jetzt auf was?
Page 5?
Da müsste irgendwas von page 5 stehen.
Macht es aber nicht.
Jetzt bin ich wieder outplayed, outflanked hier.
Gibt es da irgendwie einen Browser addon, was das kann?
Okay, dieses Video, das ist bestimmt voller Chebat.
Hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Jump to page number.
Ja, sieht schon super toll gemacht aus.
Ja, okay.
Ja, Moment, das war noch das alte.
Das ist Amazon von vor 5 Jahren.
Da ging das vielleicht noch.
Ja, auf, zeig.
Ne, page steht bei mir da nicht mehr drin.
Oder habe ich es übersehen?
Steht da irgendwo page drin?
Ne, oder?
Switched Version, View Index, Reset ID, Deals Collection, Deals Type.
Ne, ne, ne, keine Page.
Okay, Amazon, okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal testweise.
Ich weiß nicht, um was passiert, wenn ich da 8 reinschreibe.
Nix, okay.
Schau mal, View Index, wirklich?
Das, da, da, da, View Index.
Ja, aber was ist das?
Ich bin jetzt auf Seite...
Ich bin auf...
Seite 3.
Und View Index ist 2522.
Was soll das sein?
Einfach mal hier hinten 9 machen?
Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ne.
Ah, wartet mal.
Will Decode?
View Index 22.
Warte mal, das ist seit...
Oh, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, Hacker Man Time.
Das ist seit 2.
So, und jetzt seit 3.
Immer noch 22.
3?
Das...
Bei mir war das so, hab alles gelöscht.
In der Uhr.
Also direkt Prime Day, okay.
Okay.
So.
Gehen wir auf Seite 3.
Hä?
Was, und dann Next Page?
Okay.
Aber Next Page kommt genau das Gleiche.
Wir müssen Amazon outplayen, irgendwie.
Ne, keine Chance.
Fuck.
Ah, das sackt ja mal richtig.
Die 120 zwischen dem 22 und 3A, okay.
Probieren wir das nochmal aus.
Ich geh mal eins weiter.
Zwischen dem 22 und dem 3A.
Was, wo?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht...
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Ah, 120.
Ach, das hier?
Und 180 ist dann was?
Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Ach, Moment, das ist Seite 4.
Okay, also das heißt, wenn ich da jetzt mach...
Was plus 60?
Also 240 ist an Seite 5, oder was?
Ah.
Boah, big brain time.
Also, das heißt...
Das heißt...
Da musst du erst mal kommen.
Okay, also ein Schritt sind 60.
Also, ich muss auf Seite 33.
Also, 33 mal 60.
Ist die Frage, ob ich das so einfach reinschreiben kann.
Kann ich da jetzt einfach A1980 reinschreiben?
Das funktioniert.
Richtig.
Okay, jetzt haben wir Outplayed.
Jetzt haben wir gewonnen.
Jetzt finden wir die richtig geilen Deals.
Okay.
Also, unsere Top Deals sind auf...
Moment.
Numbers.
Sets.
Passt schon.
Generate.
Okay, 10 Nummern.
Zwischen 1 und 176.
Get Numbers.
Seite 9.
Also, unsere Deals sind auf Seite 9.
Alles klar.
Also, 9 mal 60.
540 müssen wir jetzt.
Jetzt haben wir sie Outplayed.
Ich finde es schon gar nicht mehr.
Wo ist es denn?
Das da?
War das das da?
Bildschirmhaltung.
Okay, also.
Jawoll, Funst. Alles da.
Hier ist unser Top.
Moment, ich muss es...
Moment, es ist minus 1.
Minus 60 am Ende noch.
Weil wir wollten Seite 9 haben.
Also, hier ist jetzt unser...
Top Angebot.
Warten wir schon mal. Also, Skip.
111.
Okay, 111 mal 60.
Minus 60. Also,
6600.
Trauen wir jetzt. 6600.
Das ist ja
maximal umständlich hier Seiten anzusteuern.
6600.
Hier ist der Deal unseres
Lebens jetzt drauf. 111.
Okay, was ist es?
Was ist es, Leute?
Ach, das beginnt erst in 12
Stunden.
Weird Champ, Alter.
Den Lüfter, den du
haben wolltest...
Ach, stimmt. Gibt es jetzt die...
Ich wollte keinen
Lüfter. Ich wollte eine
Humidifier.
Nicht den.
Wir gucken mal. Prime
und...
Das ist zwar nicht der.
Warum? Warum?
By the way, warum funktioniert...
So, und jetzt
Prime Day.
Ja, lull. Okay, gibt es
beim Prime Day nicht.
Das ist mir zu teuer, der Kram.
Also, wir müssen jetzt gucken, was gab es jetzt hier?
Das ist Seite... Das ist Seite
111. 111
wir kommen. Also, was gibt es hier?
Eine Soda Stream Flaschenbürste.
Jawoll, der Deal des Jahres.
Unterarm Trainer.
Montage... Ja, ja, ultra high quality
Werkzeug wieder.
Leute, damit baut ihr
irgendwann mal das Auto auseinander, ganz klar.
Also...
Wer damit nicht
sein Auto auseinander bekommt, ist ja mal
ein richtiger Noob.
Jo Free, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Wolo, was...
Moin Max, habe früher
immer Battlefield 3 Videos geguckt, da ist...
Ja, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
mehr Technikkrams und IT-Jobs
Sachen machen. Ich kann zu Gaming gar nicht mehr so viel
sagen. Deswegen...
Ich musste einfach die Videos jetzt auch
ein bisschen anders machen. Ging gar nicht
anders.
Lupenbrille, sieht ein bisschen aus
wie bei meinem Zahnarzt.
Für Verkleidungsteile mit dem Plastik beschädigt man das Auto nicht.
Ok, dann ist es vielleicht doch ganz
sinnvoll.
Blackhead Remover.
Was ist ein Blackhead?
Ich kenne den Fivehead, kenne ich.
Aber was ist denn
ein Blackhead?
Ist das etwa was...
was rassistisches?
Anzeige ist... Ach, was?
Mitesser?
Blackhead heißt
Das habe ich doch nie gewusst, ich
nicht.
Akkuschlaubsauger.
Taschenwaage.
Sagen wir so viele Taschenwagen, wie es da drinne gibt,
die kann man noch gar nicht brauchen.
Schwarzen
Mitesser auf der Nase.
Ok, hatte ich glaube ich noch nie.
Weil ich nicht wie das aussieht. Ich will danach aber auch nicht
googeln.
Sind das Kameras?
Sind nach innen?
Ein Pokeball, jawoll!
Ok Leute,
Random hat auch nichts gebracht. Ich glaube
Prime Day ist einfach mal wieder shit wie immer.
Also im Prinzip so wie ich es gestern schon prophezeit habe,
dass wieder nur Schrott dabei ist.
Das einzig Sinnvolle wie immer,
sind die Amazon eigenen Sachen.
Wenn man sie dann braucht.
Ansonsten, einfach useless.
Braucht kein Mensch.
Vor allem warum machen die da so einen Wind rum?
Ja, SSDs sind auch ok.
Wenn man SSDs braucht.
Ansonsten ist es komplett
komplett
unsinnig, ja.
Fire TV 4K
Ja, ich sage ja, wenn man den
Gramm braucht von Amazon selbst, ist das ganz ok.
Ok.
Du unterschätzt die Kaufsucht.
Ich kaufe mir auch gerne unsinnige Sachen.
Aber hier finde ich einfach auch das
Verhältnis von Aufwand,
den du betreiben musst, um dich da durchzukämpfen.
Und dann irgendwas findest für 7,50 Euro,
was du brauchst.
Oh nice,
der Chainlaw möchte,
hier, ich sehe es gerade,
hat gerade einen Link gepostet. Ich glaube der Chainlaw
möchte die
Ariel Zahnbürste haben, oder?
Kann das sein?
Ja.
Du solltest Amazon
Wishlist machen, dann würde ich dir jetzt eine bestellen.
Das habe ich früher auch immer
benutzt, um die Spange, um
Zahnspange zu reinigen, bin ich froh,
dass ich keine Zahnspange mehr habe. Ich habe meine
Zahnspange gehasst, Alter.
Vor allem war ich bei so einem richtig unfähigen
Kieferautopäden, dass die immer abgefallen
ist.
Also man kriegt ja da auf jedem Zahn,
kriegt man ja so einen
Metallding drauf gemacht
und die sind immer abgefallen bei mir.
Racket, genau so was. Das war richtig
Müll.
Die hat mich rausgeschmissen, meine erste
Kieferautopäde. Die hat mich wirklich
rausgeschmissen.
Nach einem Jahr oder so und
dass jedes Mal der Kram abgefallen ist,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich gesagt habe, außer dass ich das
halt total unfähig finde, dass das immer
abfällt. Und dann war sie der Meinung,
sie will mich nicht mehr behandeln. Da hat sie einen Brief geschrieben
und hat gesagt, sie
verweigert sich, mich weiter zu behandeln.
Dann bin ich nach Frankfurt gegangen,
zu einem anderen Kieferautopäde und siehe da,
da hat es wunderbar funktioniert.
Also.
Sieht man mal, was ein Schrott,
oder?
Ganz klar dein Fehler.
Ja, die haben damals erzählt, ich würde angeblich
irgendwie harte Sachen oder so essen.
Aber an einem Tag, weiß ich noch, bin ich dahin
gefahren, habe mir das wieder ganz machen lassen
und ich habe dann mittags
Tortellini gegessen.
Also, also ganz, ganz, ganz
hartes, äh, harter
Fraß, ja. Tortellini
gefuttert und ist schon wieder abgefallen.
Okay Leute, mein Fazit ist
Prime Day wieder komplett useless, sinnlos,
jebaited, outdated,
overrated,
anders kann man es nicht sagen.
Ist es schwer, den Xiaomi Mi
Temperaturen, Feuchtigkeitssender zu flaschen?
Nee, haben wir einen Stream gemacht, easy.
Wir können mal kurz gucken, ob es den hier
heute gibt.
Den da, den da.
Nee, gibt es heute nicht.
Aber der ist einfach zu flaschen, total
einfach gewesen.
Haben wir im Stream gemacht, das war
eine Sache von 5 Minuten.
Und es hat sich richtig gelohnt, den Kram
zu flaschen, weil
der Batterieverbrauch
ist richtig niedrig jetzt.
Wir haben das geflasht, das ist doch bestimmt
schon 3 Monate oder so her.
Oder 2 Monate her.
Und der ist jetzt noch bei
93% Batterie.
Das heißt, es wird richtig lang halten.
Der geht nur über Bluetooth, ja, aber das ist
kein Problem.
Ich habe
bei mir im Flur einen ESP32,
der
fragt
per Bluetooth, also es stimmt ja gar nicht, der fragt gar nicht
per Bluetooth ab, der hört einfach nur Bluetooth ab, also
Abfragen kostet zuviel
Batterie, die Dinger
broadcasten alle 30 Sekunden mal ihre
Daten. Und dann
habe ich im Flur einen ESP32
hängen, der lauscht einfach
permanent,
was Bluetooth so reinkommt und gibt dann
die Daten per MQTT an
mein Home Assistant weiter. Der fragt
aktuell, aktuell empfängt der die
Werte von
von einem Thermostat,
von meiner Waage im Bad
und von
einem Temperatursensor im Kühlschrank
und von 2 Flora
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren im Hof.
Funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, ich habe
ESP Home ganz am Anfang mal verwendet,
wo ich angefangen habe da
ESP rum zu basteln.
Ich bin aber relativ schnell auf den
Richter gekommen, dass ich den Kram lieber komplett
selbst programmiere.
Von der Waage im Bad, genau.
Ja, habe ich geadded.
Habe ich geadded, Chainlord. Ich dachte, den haben wir schon
drinnen gehabt.
Wofür fragst du die Waage über Bluetooth
ab? Naja, dass ich das Gewicht anzeigen lassen
kann. Ich habe einen Tab
für meinen Bad im Home
Assistant und dort
sehe ich dann halt was
da zuletzt drauf gewogen wurde.
Ich mache euch mal kurz aus,
ich zeige euch mal den Badetab.
Ich muss aber mal kurz ausmachen, weil ich
nicht weiß, ob ich irgendwas leake, wenn
ich es falsch aufmache.
Das kannst du dir doch
auch auf der Waage anzeigen lassen, das ist richtig,
aber du hast auf der Waage selbst keine History.
Also wenn du sehen willst, ob du
abnimmst mit der Zeit
und in welcher Geschwindigkeit
und wie das schwankt,
dann ist es ganz praktisch.
Es ist ein bisschen kaputt.
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Es ist ein bisschen broken.
Also das Gewicht, das stimmt,
aber nicht von mir.
Aber normalerweise hat man hier unten noch einen schönen
Craft und die letzten
zwei Wochen wurde da wohl nichts abgefragt.
Okay.
Aber zumindest das Fenster
ist offen, ja.
Das ist der Temperaturluftfeuchtigkeit
Sensor, der immer permanent überträgt
und hier kann ich die Heizung
anmachen. Ja, gut.
Ich bin richtig
leicht geworden.
Das wäre cool, wenn das mein Gewicht wäre.
Wie hast du die Waage eingebunden?
Wie gesagt, mit dem ESP32.
Die Waage schickt über Bluetooth raus.
Normalerweise ist es gedacht,
dass die App auf dem Smartphone das abfragt.
Und ich habe den ESP32
im Flur hängen, der das Bluetooth ausliest
und an meine Heimautomatisierung weiter schickt.
Alles gebaidet bisher. Ja, es gibt
wieder nur Müll, ausschließlich
Müll beim Prime Day.
Wirklich, also
ausschließlich 99%
Müll.
Ich wiege nicht 67 Kilo
WTF.
Jetzt bin ich ich.
Der ESP schickt über WLAN
weiter an Home Assistant.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Matter?
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es sich, also erstmal kann ein Matter
ziemlich egal sein,
bis es da ordentlich Geräte gibt. Und ich habe
so meinen Zweifel, dass ich das gut
durchsetzen wird. Weil es gibt
schon Z-Wave, es gibt ZigBee
und es gibt schon ziemlich verbreite Infrastruktur.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob sich das so wahnsinnig durchsetzen wird.
Ich meine, wozu auch?
Dass das andere Zeug funktioniert
ausreichend gut. Es braucht
Matter eigentlich gar nicht.
Leute, es gibt
nichts. Was soll ich denn jetzt noch machen?
Amazon Prime Day war voll der Reihenfall wieder.
F.
Ich konnte noch nicht mal sinnlos Geld ausgeben.
Doch, ich habe RGB
Lampen gekauft.
Zweimal Summer Sale.
Oh nee, das wird hier immer langweiliger.
3D Drucker von Forer.
Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Du brauchst einen ESD-Boden.
Das klingt teuer. Du kannst
aber auch wie Verge machen und dir einfach einen ESD-
Armband anziehen, ohne es anzuschließen.
Das reicht ja wohl angeblich auch.
Das war eh das beste Video.
Mir schicken teilweise Leute Mails,
wo ich mich frage, was wollen die von mir?
Woder von Hessen
hat mir geschrieben, dein Kundencenter ist
umgezogen.
Schön.
Solange noch alles funktioniert.
Prime Day ist da.
Ich habe auch drei Mails gekriegt,
dass Prime Day jetzt da ist.
Das habe ich auch schon festgestellt.
Leute, ich glaube, das war's.
Es gibt nichts.
Wieder wie immer.
Komplett umsonst.
Aber ich hoffe,
ihr hattet jetzt wenigstens im Homeoffice
beziehungsweise in der Mittagspause was zu tun.
Ich würde mir Twitch Prime angucken.
Nö, nicht Twitch.
Das wäre eigentlich eine geile Überleitung gewesen.
Aber Twitch Prime
könnt ihr natürlich auch loswerden.
Speed Champ 1 haben wir noch
nichts ausgemacht.
Wisst ihr, was richtig
geil wäre, wenn man beim Prime Day
Amazon-Gutscheine
kaufen könnte?
Für 50 Euro und 60 Euro
Gutschein.
Hätte man quasi infinite
Amazon-Money generieren können.
Battlefield 3 Stream
Ja, aber nicht
heute.
IP League schon wieder.
Wo war jetzt wieder IP League schon wieder?
Ach da, ja.
Ja.
Oh ne, ist wirklich
ultra langweilig. Ich hau jetzt einfach ab.
Leute, ich hau jetzt ab.
Es gibt eh nix.
Das ist ganz normales E3. E3 Gaps ist das.
Ich hau ab.
Gibt nix Gescheites. Bett gehen.
Geh mal schlafen Leute. Bis denn.
Tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal.